je sais donc que je te disais que
enquête sous haute tension c'est ton
émission préférée et bien doc gynéco
nous a proposé une autre émission pour
s'est vite s'il n'est pas content c'est
vite la regarde regardez ces enquêtes
sous basse tension c'est dans cet
immeuble du xviiie arrondissement que
nous retrouvons doc gynéco il est
seulement huit heures du mat midi quand
doc se lève enfin il roule à peine ses
vêtements en filet il quitte son
appartement il est seulement 12h30
13h50 il profite du trajet dans
l'ascenseur pour étudier le programme de
touche pas à mon poste
hop j'avais même pas que vous à jour à
cette heure ci il est à peine 15 heures
et docks et à 10 mètres de son lieu de
travail a doucement les gars pas trop
vite on n'est pas pressé 18h30
doc et au maquillage il profite de ce
moment pour se concentrer sur les
missions à venir le temps de repos que
s'accordent le chroniqueur lui sert à
être au top dans l'émission
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça n'a pas encore commencé c'est fini
plus de deux heures tp doc gynéco a
retenu la leçon
jeudi il se lèvera plus tôt afin d'être
prêt pour l'émission de lundi
qu'est ce qu'il ya en tout cas j'espère
qu'on fera mieux avec olivier j'ai pensé
à des mini scénario que j'aimerais faire
avec lui
vous savez qu'on à l'antenne on est en
direct c'est quoi les scénarios explique
peut-être à notre public qui nous
regardent à nos téléspectateurs
peut-être qu'ils vont dire voilà et vous
allez juger chez vous des idées de
sketch peut-être à venir
si vous êtes bloqué ou pas hashtag tpm p
doc gynéco
alors allez charlize theron et en os
ouais mais on va se calmer car il n'y a
pas ce qu'elle va pas rester tout le
temps valérie vais vous la connaissez
pas là valérie bénaïm d'accord alors
première étage hop une voiture de luxe
arrive c'est quoi ta voiture préférée je
parle de marque mercedes pour ferrari
vas-y mercedes porsche et ferrari
[Applaudissements]
alors ouais et je dis regarde ce que je
t'ai offert valérie et alors et moi
j'arrive je fais une roulade
vous savez faire une roulade quoi nous
montrer ouais mais attendez attendez
alors quoi tu te souviens pas comment on
fait une roulade six enfants
c'était comme ça moi je dis bon message
est rien et je pars avec toi on est
d'accord
moi j rien et je t'aime vraiment il est
on sait pas qui elle passe de boules ça
fume deux papas pardon mais qui choisir
il vous avez pons a coupé le retour
image dans la loge de charlize les peurs
qu'elle se sépare avec moi non mais je
sais pas le scénario j'ai pas compris je
dois choisir on a choisi pour l'argent
ou là où l'art l'amour vrai weppes a
réclamé afpa intérêts